hello and welcome to the very first
episode of deep dive the brand new
podcast that delves into the minds of
entrepreneurs creators and other
inspiring people to uncover their
journeys towards finding joy and
fulfillment at work and in life my name
is ali and in each episode i chat to my
guests about the philosophy strategies
and tools that have helped them along
the path to living a life of happiness
and meaning my very first guest on the
podcast is ben francis the founder and
ceo of billion dollar fitness brand
gymshark which is one of my favorite
brands in the world in our conversation
we discuss his humble beginnings making
clothes by hand in a shed with no
heating and founding jim shark at the
age of 19. and this was the moment where
it hit home because we went from doing
300 pound a day as an issue in revenue
to 30 000 pound in the first half an
hour of the website being live how he
built a viral brand and tips for getting
started with entrepreneurialism so
please feel free to grab a cup of tea
and enjoy the conversation
ben thank you so much for for joining
in the apartment welcome to the podcast
to the channel whatever we're going to
call this thank you for having me i've
been watching you for a long long time
so it's a bit surreal to actually be
here but um yeah thanks for thanks for
having me i mean that feels very bizarre
because i've been following you for a
long long time as well i think jim shark
came on my radar about like four years
or four or five years ago something like
that
i just fell in love with with a clothing
line and then when i saw that like
gymshark athletes were a thing it sort
of became a thing in my mind that oh you
know one day i'd love to be a gym shark
athlete um just as a sort of something
to work towards um so it feels very
surreal that we're sitting here now
having this conversation
um i saw something interesting on your
on your wikipedia page when i did a bit
of a stalk which said that your very
first business was selling license
plates
what was the story there so when so when
i was a kid
um our next door neighbor who's some of
my closest friends
basically
my best friend and his dad they were
just massively into cars number plates
all that sort of stuff for whatever
reason and um there was this bit where i
think they moved into a new style of
number play and you could sort of spell
names quite easily
and he would basically sell them he
would buy and he would sell them um and
at the time because i knew how to make
websites and stuff he sort of came to me
he said can you make a website for this
and long story short we ended up working
together on that and um selling plates
for a few years it was it went quite
well to be fair it was quite fun and it
was it wasn't like
a direct passion of mine it's something
i just fell into because he couldn't
take things online and it was something
that i knew about nice like how how did
you get started with the website stuff
initially oh
so i was really looking so when i was
when i was a kid i was doing my gcses um
and i wasn't particularly great at
school
not that i wasn't i wasn't like a
naughty kid or whatever it's just it
just for whatever reason i didn't
identify with me particularly well and i
probably didn't put enough effort in and
then as a result didn't get good enough
grades
um
when i think it's 16 when you finish
school yeah i think 16 finished in
school um
i basically ended up getting into sixth
form but it was under the idea that i
did i had to do english literature as
one a level i did business as one a
level um and they they asked me to do
english for some reason because i just
happened to do well it was the one it
was probably the one subject where i
didn't have to apply myself to do well
which was weird
um business studies and i did a b tech
in it
now the be taking it was life changing
for me because
anyone that's that i mean i'm not sure
how it works now but the old sort of
rule of thumb was a levels was more test
oriented btec was more coursework
oriented and for me that was quite cool
because it was a like it felt to me at
the time like a pla a practical
application of skill yeah
um so in that one of the modules you had
like your standard modules but one of
them was about web development and it
was really cool for me because it was
just a case of
make a website and they gave us
access to the adobe creative suite and
that was
one of the most pivotal and
life-changing moment for me because
that's when i ended up learning you you
had i think you could go down two routes
you either made or you made a website
and front page and you made a website
using dreamweaver
and it just gave me that basic knowledge
of web development but because we got
access to the whole creative suite i
then learned how to use photoshop and
illustrator and all these different
things which
anyone that's made websites or anything
on you know any sort of digital products
will know that you can't just have a
website without graphics you know how to
make all these different things so um
yeah it was through it the btec it which
i originally learned how to do things
like that oh okay that's really
interesting so my my story is is kind of
similar um it was uh it classes in year
eight
when i saw um i saw one of the kids in
the year above was was leaving and i saw
that he'd he
he got on the google home page and he'd
right clicked view source and there was
all this code floating around yeah and i
was like oh my god this is this guy's a
hacker i need to i need to understand
how this code thing works and then in
ict classes and then at break times and
lunch times because you know all my
friends were nerds um i go to the
computer room and i started dabbling in
in web design as well you know started
off in front page pirated dreamweaver
pirated photoshop
back in the day photoshop cs2 things
like that yeah um but i think it's so
interesting how
a lot of people i've spoken to who have
ended up doing entrepreneurial things
have started from the i knew how to make
websites front um is that something that
you've seen itself 100 but it's because
you see this in a lot of areas right
it's because not that many people were
doing it because i remember because then
the the next step for me which i didn't
learn in it but i ended up learning
myself was was app development and i
sort of it was around 17 18 years old i
wanted to go into app development
because no one else was doing app
development so web development was cool
but like it got to the point where it's
almost like you know when you start to
learn a new skill you learn a lot really
quickly then you get to a level then it
starts to slow down and it felt like i'd
sort of
i was at a crossroads i could either
double down on web development and
really try and be great and it felt like
everyone was doing it or i could try app
development i think
it was like the apple sdk you paid 20 30
40 quid i remember what it was you pay
the fee and it basically gives you
access to
like the sdk basically so then i moved
on to app so i think
a lot of people did well out of websites
sort of in our era because not that many
people were doing it and there was so
much opportunity and then i think it
went to apps and you know now it's sort
of beyond that even yeah
yeah i think like especially with like
websites and apps and i think now things
like tick-tock and stuff are where as an
individual you don't need to ask
anyone's permission you can just make
something completely from scratch yeah
so nowadays these websites then later on
so now
these days i feel like
the kids are less into websites and apps
just more into content yeah once you
have that confidence that you can make
something from nothing then the ideas
start to flow like license plates or
whatever and so the thing that
fascinated me about the web right was
and to be honest it's still the case i
think i think a lot of people a lot of
young kids know will look at the web
look at apps look at social and they'll
think well it's all been done
everything's been done no ideas left
whatever but there's so much opportunity
we'll look back at this period in 10 20
30 years time as like
the moment of opportunity
um the thing that i loved about the web
i'll never forget this so when we first
started the gymshark website we couldn't
really get traffic there
um but we then found out that we could
make thousands of products in the back
end and call them all these different
things and google shopping would index
them right at the top of the page for
free yeah and it's like almost like you
couldn't do it now but there were so
many little opportunities like that
little
hacks probably too you know strong a
word but those little hacks and tricks
that you could do
to sort of get ahead and i still think
there's so many opportunities like that
on all these different platforms that
we're talking about
okay awesome so
you
learn how to website and learn how to do
websites with the with the itv tech then
you started doing the license plate
selling how did that business go
it was all right we did it for
maybe a year or two so i did it in that
period where i was finishing school and
then going into university with the guys
um it was fun it was a good learning
experience it was like
it was basically your typical website it
was just a
select selection of pages which showed
stock and then all of the sales would be
done on email or on the phone so again
it gives you that understanding of
buying things selling things having
websites it wasn't a transactional
website yeah um you know understanding
deals on the phone that sort of stuff so
it it was like it was a great learning
curve for me okay
and then what kind of so you said app
design came next how did that happen so
after that it was just making apps and
yeah um
i learned everything i know about app
design or i say i knew about app design
because i wouldn't know where to start
now um everything i knew about app
design on youtube and i've just watched
different youtubers and they do like
tutorials and the first couple of apps
easiest thing i think to make was like a
web browser because it was like
it took like 10 15 minutes to make sort
of thing
made a couple of different web browsers
and then this is where i started
thinking i sort of built up my skills
and i could do different different
things and i thought right how can i how
can i actually make this practical and
because by this point i was really
falling in love with the gym and fitness
that's when i thought right maybe i
could make some fitness apps and again
very very basic like
nothing extraordinary in any way shape
or form but there were apps where you'd
sort of go in and it would have workouts
in the app and then you could go into
the calendar section hit save this five
day split and it would automatically
populate your calendar with with a
workout basically and give you a little
reminder to do it and for me it was less
around almost like the product but it
was me my sort of learning curve and i
had this aim of right i want to make an
app and i want to make an app that i can
get live on the store because apple had
albeit fairly low guard rails but they
would definitely like double check that
the app was sort of robust enough to go
on the store so i really wanted to be
able to do that and
made two web browsers which was just
basic as anything two fitness apps and
it was basically just around getting in
shape oh wow so what was this while you
were at university or when you were like
it was either last year at high school
first year uni i think it was last year
at high school so you're like a
full-time student doing like studying
and stuff and then on i guess weekends
and evenings and school holidays just
like messing around on a computer making
maps which was great fun because like i
said it just felt like you were doing
stuff that no one else was doing you
were doing something that because i just
love the apple brand and i would be that
kid that would watch all of the keynotes
when steve jobs would walk out and i was
just like i just adored him and the
brand so much
um
for me it was like that thing of i just
want to be involved in it any way shape
or form and you know you'll know this as
well as i do then you start learning
something and it gets addictive and then
you start going on the forums and you're
getting involved in the little
communities and i mean to this day i
love being involved in all the different
communities like from i mean at the time
it was app development web development
that was like motorcycles and fitness
but
um yeah it sort of gave me a little bit
of a home as well wow okay yeah that's
really cool um so then you went to uni
what did you study at uni so i went to
aston university and i studied business
management okay
so i'm i'm considering potentially doing
a business degree at some point maybe
like an mba and a lot of people have
have said to me that maybe it's not
particularly useful because once you've
run a business you learn a lot more
about business by running it then by
doing a degree what what
on that yeah i think it depends so we
basically what we did at aston is they
have um a common first year i don't know
how uh consistent that is across
different universities and then the the
aim of the common first year for all
business students was to give you a
solid grounding on everything so you did
a couple of modules on legals
accountancy modules finance maths um
business management
um all these different things so i
actually think that gave me a great
grounding
and it albeit we did make mistakes in
the early days the fact that i knew
about trademarks and how important it
was intellectual property and had that
basic knowledge it actually really
really helped me and i was confident
enough and understanding the different
sort of classes of trademarks i was
getting trademarks early in you know
gymshark yeah so it definitely gave me a
basic knowledge but yeah i do agree i
think if you are going to run a business
then you are going to i i think that's
sort of slightly separate you won't
learn
the things you would learn starting a
business through a degree but equally
vice versa because
running a business you learn things as
you do them and the problem is is
because you don't know what you don't
know if you don't know that you need
trademarks or strong ip
then you'll never think about it whereas
the business course will actually give
you that grounding yeah so this is a
problem we're having in our business
right now whereby i've sort of been
making making [ __ ] up as i went along
for the last four years and
you know we've we've now got a team of
12 people and we're trying to hire like
five more
and just even thinking you know like
what is a director of opera operations
what's the director of marketing like
that apparently that's a thing and
i just don't know what i don't know and
it's only when i speak to people who are
on businesses and i describe my problems
when they say oh yeah that sounds like
you need a director of marketing and i
guess that's the sort of stuff that you
got a kind of reasonable foundation in
before before starting gymshark yeah 100
but i would also say that there's like
this weird thing of there are there is a
conventional way of running a business
and there's a there is a way that you'll
be taught and that tends to be based on
the old-school business models so yes
having a grasp of what a different the
different areas of a c-suite will do is
is very very important but equally like
in your business you're doing something
that really hasn't ever been done at a
reasonable scale like granted there's
there's massive like people there's huge
companies that will do similar sorts of
things but compared to where they'll be
in 10 20 years it's it's completely
the other thing as well and i speak
about this quite a bit so i've been
really lucky to be around some
incredibly inspiring talented and
successful business people like
running businesses far far larger than
jim shark and all of them to a degree
are winged in it like genuinely all of
them so
again it's like i always think about it
and this it hit me it's gonna sound
weird but it hit me when i first walked
into the gym right
i was 15 16 years old and i walked into
the gym and i was trying to do a bicep
curl
and i didn't know what i was doing i
felt really self-conscious you know i it
felt like the whole world was looking at
me and going who's that kid messing
around with with those weights but in
reality everyone was sort of working
like worried about themselves and they
were all thinking the same thing and
they some of them were probably looking
at me thinking oh he knows what he's
doing when he doesn't and yeah it's it's
the same in many ways of of business
granted there's some incredibly talented
people and they've learned a lot but
anything that's new everyone is winging
it and working out as they go along even
up to the multi-billion dollar
corporations
yeah
have you have you got any examples of
like when you when you realize that that
was a thing in in the world of business
so basically gymshark has been built on
shopify since day one pretty much like
we we ended up moving off shopify it
didn't go very well we moved back and
we've had an incredible relationship
with them for a long long time
and i'm really fortunate because
harley who's now president and he's been
he was the chief operating officer for a
long long time at shopify um there was a
guy who ran shopify plus called lauren
um brief conversations with toby who
founded the business
and the fact that they sort of took us
under their wing in many respects and
sort of i would i would ask harley
questions and he would be like
i you know i don't know we haven't
worked out either and this is one of the
largest i think this is canada's biggest
company or one of canada's biggest
company like thousands of employees
such an inspiring group of people
you know there's other people that have
spoken to it as well there's um a good
friend of mine called jars who runs a
company called akqa again i would ask
him questions and he's just like
yeah you can just work it out i think
there's not this prescriptive rule book
like
some of the greatest minds in the world
might not know the answers to your
problems because they're unique and they
need to be solved in a unique way yeah
yeah i i had a similar moment it was it
was a few weeks ago so we've got we've
got a guy on our team uh jakub who helps
out with marketing and stuff yeah and i
was saying to jakob all right jacob you
know we need this like you know dream
director of marketing i want to be able
to
basically say to them that we want to
hit 3 million youtube subscribers next
year and they'll be able to come up with
a strategy yeah and he was like
i'm not sure they would because if you
imagine a director of marketing maybe
they've got an mba or something like
that but he was saying that like you
know you as the youtuber you know far
more about how to grow on youtube and
these directors of marketing would be
looking to you for how to grow their
brands yeah and i was like whoa but i
just make it up as i go along
it was like yeah but you know people
would literally hire you to be a
consultant to tell them how to grow on
youtube which just again speaks to that
thing that everyone's everyone's just
figuring it out it's true it's true and
so we have a similar sort of thing where
we were looking at marketing but
marketing is it's so many different
things to different people we've
actually moved it in a slightly
different angle where we'll have like a
chief of brand and then marketing sits
elsewhere in the business because then
we would split our organic approach in
our more quantitative approach to
marketing or like a paid approach so
listen everyone does things in different
ways and equally i know companies that
have a more conventional model that are
wildly successful as well so i just
think it's what works for you yeah and i
guess part of it is
i suppose part of it is just like the
semantics like do you call it marketing
do you call it brand yeah do you call it
strategy like for us it's like
we call it content because most of our
content is
most of our stuff is content but then
you call it product you call it
operations all this kind of stuff and i
think the boxes do have their place but
also just that recognition that okay
does this department belong in
operations or belong in marketing who
cares like the point is they're
researching content ideas exactly
exactly like when you get to the nuts
and bolts of it that's what you need to
be thinking about rather than just the
names one one thing i'm curious about i
saw your you did a video about black
friday i think it was last year where
there was a lot of references to how you
were working very closely with shopify
yeah and that seemed really interesting
to me because obviously i've been
following shopify for years and i know
of shopify is i paid 29 a month and i i
figure it out and do it myself and i
message their support once in a while
yeah but it seems you guys have a much
more like integrated like
what does that look like at gymshark
scale working with a company like
shopify so
the i think one so we we're very
culturally aligned with shopify the way
that jim shark and chopra works is very
very similar
and there's periods in time where
there'll be a group of people from
shopify will fly over from canada and
spend time working in the gym shark
office particularly around black friday
and sort of sales periods
and you wouldn't know they wouldn't
stick out you know what i mean it's like
everyone's very very similar because jim
shark has
very very high levels of traffic anyway
and we have super high levels of traffic
around times like black friday for
whatever reason jim shop becomes super
attractive around those sorts of times i
think it's because we tend not to do too
many sales
now because the spikes are so high
there's been periods in the past where
we've broken all of shopify's records in
terms of people jumping on the website
in a in a moment so we basically need
people on hand to make sure that the
website is running in a robust way
because we've had periods in the past
where it has fallen apart and hasn't
gone well okay so what will tend to
happen so black friday is just gone
shopify will send a group of individuals
over and we'll be managing the website
live in our office obviously they'll be
shopify staff so they'll have access to
all of shopify systems and then you'll
have the gymshark guys sort of next to
them managing our side of things as well
it's like mission control yeah like it's
incredible just to see it all going on
because a lot of the sort of extra
things and add-ons that we have onto our
website and a lot of even some of our
analytics tools in real time will break
just due to the amount of traffic that
we've that we're receiving in that
moment
okay that's pretty cool
i guess when you get to that level of
scale you're starting to solve these
sorts of problems that stuff that i
never thought we would have to solve for
but um
yeah shopify is such a great platform
and that's why it works for us is they
do really support us and help us during
those sort of peak periods nice yeah i
actually got an email from one of their
marketing people the other day being
like hey we want to work with you about
entrepreneurship content i was like yes
sure that's cool
sweet so um
so if we go back to kind of you would
you were doing the apps around around
fitness yeah um
when did gymshark become a thing like
relative to the app design stuff so it
was 2012 when the company was founded um
and the reason it was started was one i
wanted a website with that that would
transact so before that i've made the
basic number plate website i've done all
these different basic apps i messed
around with a few wordpress websites
fitness forums tried to make a little
fitness social network
it was all just a bit messy um it wasn't
particularly great and then it was like
right i've done all these different
things let's do a website that would
transact that's where i stumbled upon
shopify
right in 2012
that would have been really early days
very yeah it was early days very basic
but it was just again it was just a
simple solution of transacting online
which is great for us
now because essentially there was the
time wasn't taken up with massive hours
on development then we were really
thinking carefully about the product and
i really wanted to be involved in
fitness by any way that i could and at
the time i was massively into
supplements i think anyone that first
gets into the gym you like look at all
the different nutrition you hear about
how important it is and i went to a mate
of mine worked at a local company and i
said to him i want to stock supplements
on the website what's your minimum order
and the minimum order was eight thousand
pound for supplements now i'd never
heard of eight thousand pound let alone
seen eight thousand pound at the time i
was at pizza on it was four pounds
something an hour it was just i wouldn't
have been able to afford that so i sort
of sat down and now sort of the term
drop shipping you know it's i think it's
a term that a lot of people will
understand and for those of you that
don't it's basically you don't hold
stock um someone orders from you and
basically you act as a middleman someone
else ships out to the customer
now at the time i'd never heard of drop
shipping but i had this sort of idea of
okay so i've got limited knowledge of a
website and i know around how google
works i know that i want a large website
i want it to be broad i want a vast
product array i want lots of pages i
want it to index well in google it's
brand new it's it's not going to be seen
otherwise so what i did was i drop
shipped
loads of supplements from the jim
charles website filled it up with loads
and loads of supplements wasn't making
great margin but it was again if we're
looking back to the bar that was set the
very low bar of i want to be involved in
fitness and i want a website that
transacts so i'd sort of filled that
right even though we didn't own the
stock did that for a while and took a
few months got a sale first sale i was
dancing around my bedroom like it was
the best feeling ever first thing
someone bought something yeah someone
bought
is at the point where like you almost
forget about it it's like running the
background i think we were paying
shopify a few quid a month the domain
cost demand cost me three pound fifty so
about sort my investment costs would
have yeah
20 quid round numbers as i guess so you
sort of forget about it
got the sound i was just buzzing it was
a 50 pound sale and we made two pounds
profit on it but
it was a sale
um did that kept going started to get
the odd sale like a sale every week and
so on and
and um basically i bought a a tank
because i was obsessed with bodybuilding
i wanted to be i'd sort of realized i
was never going to be a footballer i
wanted to be a bodybuilder
so i bought this tank online like an
arnold schwarzenegger style stringer
tank and it just completely drowned me
basically fell through the middle of it
because it was built for a big
bodybuilder not someone like me with
more of a slender frame so at that point
i thought right i would love for us just
to make our own clothing because no one
makes the clothing that we want um
conveniently my name was doing a
curtains course my mom knew how to sew
local lad knew how to screen print so
saved up bought a screen printer or a
sewing machine
and started to make the clothes from
there
so you went from supplements to clothes
yes
because you saw a problem that you
wanted those clothing that looked a
certain way it was like a selfish
problem right yeah i wanted this
stringer i looked terrible in it i was
looking around online no one was making
the product that we wanted um so we did
it and it was at that weird time right
where
i loved the colorful when you bodybuild
an aesthetic
a lot of the american product just
wasn't really coming over to the uk and
that that was it didn't fit in the way
that we wanted things over in europe and
the uk were starting to get a lot more
fitted and tapered it was that you know
topman two for ten pound era when
everyone wore skinny jeans and little
tight tops so it was like that weird
morphing of okay so i wanna be able to
look like a bodybuilder but i just
haven't got the size this was like the
fashion over here so all of a sudden the
idea came how great would it be to make
fitness wear that would really
accentuate your physique and tape it
taper yourself in
and that's when we started to make the
clothes okay
so
what was the trajectory then so you
start hand making the clothes when when
did things start to really take off i
would guess
2015 okay about 2015 so about three
years in and that was when we did our
first body power our first event
basically and that was the trigger point
where all of a sudden it went from being
this thing that i did from 10 p.m till
1am to i'm now going all in on this okay
and it was it was around that first
event that we did and what happened at
that first event
so so as a kid so about 20 minutes from
where i grew up the birmingham nec so
it's a large event space
and every year they would do an event
called body power so my heroes these
american lifters bodybuilders they would
all fly in everyone have have a huge
fitness event once a year
so i would go as a kid um
and then the one year that we went which
would have been 2014 i believe 2013
2014.
and i was walking around and jim shark
existed and this time it was it was sort
of drop shipping supplements we're in
that bit where i'm about to buy the
screen printer and sewing machine
and i'm walking around
i'm just thinking jim shark has to be
here like which was mental because we
had no stock at the time there was no
physical manifestation of gymshark and i
just had this
gut-wrenching feeling that we had to be
here by any means necessary so i'm
walking around and i'll never forget i'm
in a bit of a rush because i'm there on
the day and i know i've got my pizza
shift at five and it was coming to like
three o'clock i'm thinking right i need
to sort of
make an action here and do something
because i need to get to work
and i've gone to the show office and
funnily enough the guy that runs it
who's now a friend of mine called ollie
and it was steve as well who were there
and he just said right i want to stand
cheapest down you can get give me a
stand i want to be here next year what's
the price and it was three grand
again three grand was a hell of a lot of
money but now it was more reasonable
that within 12 months i could earn 3 000
pounds because i had the job jim sharp
was starting to get a few sales
it wasn't crazy so
there and then booked into the stand um
followed it up on email got it going
then over the next year gymshark started
we started making the close we started
getting regular sales we actually
started to become a profitable business
so upgraded the stand started to um work
more closely with some of my heroes who
were youtubers
um and we basically brought those guys
to this event
so we'd we'd stumbled upon
the market mix that many online people
use today right we'd
we'd had a product that was only
available at this event we'd
accidentally built scarcity because we
turned the website off while we were
there
not through a strategic decision but
because because we weren't making the
close we had to turn the website off
because otherwise people might order and
not get them sent
um we flew these youtubers in who were
again not strategic just our heroes and
i just really wanted to meet them um and
then we would go to this event and we
were starting to build a community
because at the end of each day we were
just going lift down the road in
ironworks in birmingham and just get a
lifting with you know me my friends
the athletes the local fans and we were
building this community so
as we were doing this lifting and
whatnot people were taking pictures they
were putting on facebook and the brand
started to go viral without us really
knowing
so the event went incredibly well we
completely sold out of everything and
then after the event turned the website
back on and and and this was the moment
where it hit home because we went from
doing 300 pound a day as an issue in
revenue to 30 000 pound in the first
half an hour of the website being live
and he just went it was like boom
overnight and going back to that like
the website everything was set to
infinite stock because we would never
get enough sales to ever trouble the
scoreboard yeah so i'm there at 1
o'clock in the morning scrambling on my
laptop trying to turn all the stock to
zero to cancel everything off because we
were just getting so many sales
um and there was a point where
everything's out of stock on the website
i've closed my laptop it's one o'clock
in the morning yeah 30 grand worth of
outstanding sales
um
and that was a moment where i was like
wow i'm on to something here something's
something is really going to like kick
off with this company
what does that feel like like can you
remember kind of your thoughts and
feelings at the time as like this sort
of your 100x basically overnight so that
was the period where um
sort of like i dropped out of uni like
the week before
um you know i was i was starting to
really dig in so i felt like i was then
taking albeit not massive it didn't feel
like massive financial risk albeit you
know the stand cost everything that we
had to fly the youtubers over everything
we had we'd we'd risked everything we
had several times
um
but it was i just felt really excited to
be honest and the thing that we did well
which i'm really proud of
is we didn't rest at that point we did
one great event so then the next year we
did two the next year we did five and we
just went and went and went and we kept
spending everything we had
on
punts that we thought might come off but
the stuff that our gut told us was the
right thing to do nice
so between let's say 2013 and 2015 like
before this event how were people
finding the supplements and the clothing
like um what sort of marketing penny
were you guys you guys doing so facebook
was massive at the time
youtube
uh and google were the main three things
so it was the whole google shopping
thing was massive for us
there was a change where all of a sudden
you had to pay for your spot on google
shopping which sort of affected us but
it's sort of like a bit of an evolve or
die moment so that was the point where
we actually started getting involved
with a little bit of paid advertising
facebook instagram wasn't really a thing
so yeah facebook youtube and google so
facebook is in facebook groups or
facebook ads like what facebook pages
was the thing
which everyone would comment on and yeah
um i mean we ended up building up to
well over a million followers which at
the time was just yeah that's something
um and that was back in
2015 2016. okay and then on youtube okay
what's the thing of like sending product
to people and yeah so this is the thing
so we didn't we've not really done too
much on youtube and and at the time so
it was going back to my heroes it was
those guys that were great youtubers i
say great youtubers matt who was the
biggest at the time had 20 000 subs
which by today's numbers are quite small
they're our heroes they're uploading
regularly on youtube i would love i
remember thinking like lex griffin who's
one of the first athletes he lives up in
manchester i remember thinking i'd love
lex to try on our top try on our tank
and give us some feedback and then he
just happened to wear it on youtube and
that's where i think youtube really
kicked off for us we're going to take a
very quick break to introduce our
sponsor for this episode and that is
brilliant i've been using brilliant for
the last two plus years they're a
fantastic platform for learning maths
science and computer science with
engaging and interactive online courses
and the great thing about brilliant is
that they really teach stuff from a very
first principles based approach it's
almost like the way that we were taught
in places like oxford and cambridge
where you learn a concept and then you
apply the concept to an interesting
problem rather than just being spoon-fed
stuff like we initially learned in
school my favorite courses on brilliant
are the computer science ones as some of
you guys might know i was torn between
applying to medicine and computer
science i went for medicine in the end
but i always had an affinity to computer
science and taking the courses on
brilliant like their introduction to
algorithms and their introduction to
python really helped me get more of a
grasp of computer science than i've ever
had before it's also great for learning
how to code which is an incredibly
useful skill to have especially if you
want to start a business and i attribute
like 98 of my business success to the
fact that i learned how to code when i
was in secondary school so if you want
to check out the courses on math science
and computer science then head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to sign up with
that link will get 20 off the annual
premium subscription so thank you
brilliant for sponsoring this episode
and so while while all this was
happening you were working at pizza
yes so i ended up quitting pizza around
around the event around the event when
things really started to take off yeah
and a quick beat and university around
the same time so it was a little bit
like i remember my mom and dad being a
little bit like are you sure this is
what you want to do and it's just like
yeah i'm i'm gonna go and give it a go
so one of the questions i get all the
time and i know you've recently done a
video about this is like how how do you
have time to do all these things so you
know early days of jim shark you're
running this business on the side you're
working at pizza hut you're at uni like
what was your
what was your time management looking
like at the time well i just want to say
so my time management then and now are
vastly different just completely
different so back then it was
university which i mean you know
university it's like it's not like a
solid night until five is it like you'll
have busier days and quieter days so
basically university in the day peter
shifts would always be ten five till ten
normally half ten
latest eleven by the time you sort of
washed up because as a driver you do the
pot wash when you're in the in the
building and then it would be ten or
eleven onwards i would work on jim sharp
now stream shots started to grow we'd
have live chats emails and stuff so
pizza was great for me because i could
do a delivery then sit in my car respond
to two or three emails and carry on so
i'm doing two things at the same time
and yeah that was that period where
i think it was the iphone 3gs i think it
was my first iphone and i got my hands
on one and i'm like buzzing because i
can literally work on the go so i was
like almost doing two jobs at once
whilst i was at pizza which was
absolutely brilliant for me nice and
what does your time management look like
now
incredibly well
just scheduled organized everything down
to the second it's it's it's actually
really cool and for me at the start it
was really difficult to get used to
because i just love the whole thing of
doing whatever the hell i want when i
wanted to do it but now i've learned to
be really disciplined um and essentially
because i am horrifically unorganized
essentially outsourcing that to people
who are incredibly well organized and
absolutely love doing that sort of stuff
it's great for me because i know i
basically wake up and it's like a set of
train tracks right every minute pretty
much from seven or eight in the morning
tends to be planned until seven or eight
on the evening so what does that look
like on a standard day like what are the
day in the life of ben francis it varies
so much it's it's well different now
because i'm not traveling so it's
actually really it's simple because it's
like there's one moving part whereas
before moving around we've got offices
in hong kong mauritius denver events
that we would do all over the world it
was it was manic
now it would be i'd usually i usually
try and get into the office around
seven half seven basically just meetings
throughout it could be
there'll be a particular day for example
with one-on-ones in the team so people
that i work directly with
um there'll be certain projects that i'm
working on and then we may be on
there'll be certain days allocated to
those things
um once a week or every other week i'll
be in london so they'll sort of batch up
the london meetings and do all the
london meetings on a particular day
i'll get involved with all sorts of
different things whether it's you know
content on my youtube the only thing i
would say is now it's changed because
i'm moving into a ceo role so i'm now
just one step slightly more removed
whereas previously it would be product
and
or brand whereas now i'm chatting with
the people that are doing those things
which is again just a slightly different
thing to get used to okay yeah we'll
come back to the ceo thinking a bit
because i really really want to kind of
explore that um so
going back to sort of imagining some
kind of 2014 2015 before the
the nec show
what did the team look like
in gymshark
there was
um
myself and lewis who started the
business there was my brother
so in around 2015 i think it was my
brother so basically my brother was the
first employee and the whole thing of
joe joining the business was we're at
the event we need someone back at the um
back at the um
the ranch to sort of manage the stock
and then that was it really like a few
friends ended up joining and doing you
know bits here and there
but it was just everyone would just get
involved in everything like if there was
a busy day we would jump on customer
service like everyone would finish the
end of the day
sat in a circle on their laptops and
they would answer customer queries um
so it really varied i just remembered by
the way it was 2012 not 2015 that we did
that first event 12 2013 so it was
around that sort of era okay so you had
sort of a team of maybe three poor
people yeah so it was in that first
event it was like two or three and then
as it developed then it was like okay
and then we started to invest more in
the warehouse because we had our own
warehouse and we would ship our own
product okay then people would basically
manage customer service and deliveries
and stuff at what point did you get the
warehouse like that's been a big expense
yeah so 2012 2013 just before that first
event that was when we got like a shed
basically right okay honestly
it was it was actually not not
particularly great it was it was a shed
on an industrial estate and i didn't
realize until about three or four months
in the whole thing was built out of
asbestos oh no and like the bloke next
door like this
lovely lad like 80 years old he was he
was just like drilling through the walls
through the asbestos walls and all
asbestos was just flaking everywhere so
that's probably not great for my health
um so it was an old asbestos shed in the
middle of nowhere on an industrial state
and it cost us about 300 quid a month i
think 250 300 quid a month okay then
after that we ended up going into a more
professional sort of place we went from
that was 300 square feet and then the
next one we actually upgraded to three
or three thousand square foot warehouse
and what was great about that is it had
a small room
um at the front of it with a radiator in
and if anyone's work worked in like a
shed through the winter it was
ice cold so to have a radio it was
amazing because what we used to have to
do we'd have the front door of our old
shed we'd leave the door open and we'd
stick a diesel heater in there so you go
over next door you get your diesel from
the pump and you basically you'd fill it
up and then it would just blast heat in
there but again
sat in an asbestos shed with a diesel
heater blowing at you is not the most
exciting way of spending your late
teenage years or early 20s so to have a
radio it was game changing radio was
game changing right and i guess whether
you and your mates making the clothes
yes like hand making the clothes yeah
yeah so like getting cloth and like
cutting it up so this yeah and so the
sewing would be done at home essentially
and then we would print uh generally at
the
the um i don't know what you call it
warehouse wow okay so
when you're in those early days and
you're investing in things like the
radiator the warehouse and stuff yes um
what's going through your mind in terms
of like the profitability of this like
don't think about anything like that
didn't think like i had no idea how to
pay taxes i had no idea about finances
all we knew was more was coming in that
was going out okay and
everything beyond that is just
at the time it was fluff clearly now
that's not the case um but it was
everything was purely instinctive
everything at the start okay so you
start off as like a band of band of
brothers like you know a handful of
people in a shed yeah a radiator is a
game-changing expense yeah a
game-changing addition to the business
and now james shark is a billion plus
dollar company you're the new ceo of it
like how many employees do you do you
know uh we're just over 700 700 and you
sell all of the world with offices all
around the world that's going to feel
pretty wild like it's cool it's called
honestly i still walk into the hq so
we've got a gorgeous hq and there's the
sort of the big logo on the front over
the road we've got our lifting club
we've got like a gym manufacturing
facility studios i do walk in and
like i do still get goosebumps because
it's it's such an amazing place and
there's a buzz like you've got to visit
because as soon as you walk in the door
there's a buzz there and everyone's
lovely everyone's pulling in the same
direction everyone really understands
why we do what we do
everyone understands the area that they
sort of fit in with that sort of wider
plan
it's it's such a lovely place to be
so
it's interesting you say that like
everyone's putting in the same direction
because i think i feel like
this is an issue we're having as we
expanded from three people to 12 people
whereby i'm now having starting to do
things like defining our vision and
where we want to be in x number of years
and kpis and goals and all this stuff
that in the past i would have thought
this is all just corporate [ __ ] like
who cares about any of that
um
presumably like like
what was your journey through kind of
being more businessy about it so what
you're going through yeah so we did that
i used to hate the word corporate and
you're going through for reading between
the lines what i actually think is the
most difficult change i think this is
one of the most difficult things for any
entrepreneur or business person and by
the way not even owning your own
business if you're
running or working in a great business
it's so difficult to sort of distribute
that control and
i think those that can do that then
after that it's not plain sailing but if
you've then done that it's like you know
it's like a muscle memory right if you
continue to do that i think scaling
becomes so much easier
um i'll give you so my sort of breakdown
i sort of break it down into three areas
and i think every great business person
needs to reinvent themselves over and
over again so you can't become too like
tied in or emotionally attached to sort
of i'm gonna say who you are in many
respects so at the start i found
i had a great creative vision i didn't
exist i had a great idea where i wanted
us to be and i i felt like i dragged the
business to where i wanted us to be and
that sounds a bit sort of direct but you
know it could be having a great creative
vision it could be great at knowing
product it could be great at whatever it
is but
you because you tend to be a one-man
band or there's not many people involved
you just do what the hell you want when
you want and it's very instinctive
now you'll then get to a stage where
you've got people around you it might be
five people it might be 10 people it
might be 30 people
and an instinctive way of running things
is still great but you can't just do
things on a whim because you fancy you
have to then learn to work in a team and
i don't mean when i say in a team i mean
you are part of the team and anyone
that's managed a team knows that the
team doesn't work for you you work for
them and you need to make sure that
you're really understanding how to work
with each different type of people
person so some people will love to be
organized and they will love lots of
different catch-ups and you know some
people will be highly creative some
people will be highly logical some
people you'll have to spend six weeks
trying to buy them into a new dear new
idea some people have to spend six
seconds and it's about learning how to
work with all these different people so
you've gone from dragging the business
to where you wanted it to be learning to
work with new people and then
that sounds like to a degree what you're
going through slash the next stage which
is like okay you don't have to work with
people
how do we galvanize them around a vision
or a mission how do we make them
understand where they fit in with that
how do we make them understand that
you know the team that we're working
with touch what is greater than the sum
of its parts and really understanding
how to articulate yourself and your
vision um
and essentially learning how to inspire
people and i think that's again it's
very tough and
i hear people a lot of the time saying
like
oh you know
one facet of their personality that's
just me what am i like i'm a bit
unorganized well
when you're at that level there's not
there's no excuse for being an organizer
like yes i am an organized but you do
something about it you either fix it
yourself or you build the team in a way
that negates that weakness does that
make sense
it's um i think it gets a bit more
serious at that point and yeah you have
to learn new skills and tourists that's
why i love the job so much and feel like
i've got the best job in the world
because you're constantly learning new
things and constantly reinventing
yourself it sounds like that's what
you're going through now a bit yeah it
seems like a real a real shift in where
my default used to be i want to do
something all right i'll do it i was
like i want to do something okay
let's figure out why i want to do this
thing let's figure out like what the
actual like what good looks like to
figure out who i can give this project
to let's give them ownership over it in
a way that they'll feel more motivated
to do it i mean kind of get out of the
way and be there to kind of consult them
if they need it but not like step on
their toes too much
the most exciting thing about that
period is right you'll have it there'll
be there'll be a few things that'll
happen and it happened to me
someone will do something you'll trust
them with it they'll do it poorly and it
will break your heart
but someone will do something that you
didn't think was the right thing to do
and it will be infinitely better than
any ideas that you would have come up
with
and that is one of the most fulfilling
and incredible experiences ever because
then you're like okay now we're a team
yes yeah i've had that i've had that a
few times um i often describe this
feeling when because i i teach people
how to be
how to be uh part-time youtubers and one
of the things i'm very bullish on is to
outsource editing like asap
and everyone is very resistant oh but i
like editing i like doing it myself i i
enjoy spending 20 hours a week doing my
editing and i'm like look guys the
moment you outsource editing like just
that feeling when you upload raw footage
of yourself mumbling through a video on
google drive and the next day you get
back an edited video and it's actually
really good it just like blows your mind
and then you think oh my god like i've
just
like my my whole world is now open and i
guess what you're describing is that at
scale when you have a team that can
execute stuff exactly like i said and i
i love it i love working with so many
different types of people and there was
a there was a point a few years ago
basically when i i moved into a role as
the chief marketing officer at gymshark
and cheap market at the time was all
your quantitative marketing it was all
your social media and it was all data i
remember going into this role thinking
love marketing love social media
not a clue where to start with data and
to be honest it sounds a bit boring but
i ended up working with the data team
and that ended up being the team i loved
working with the most because they would
run rings around me at the start and
like i would come in with all my
stupid irrational ideas that just made
no sense and would have flopped
instantly and they would challenge me
and it made me a better person and in
terms of sharpening up my ideas and my
concepts but equally it meant that i
learned the power of what they do and
you know the validity of it so it was
massively fulfilling to me to work with
a team that i didn't expect to enjoy
working with or be good at working with
and to be able to do that nice
so when you're
when you're the kind of founder of the
business and like the owner of the
business how did you kind of get to that
point where your role was chief
marketing officer rather than straight
to ceo like what was going through your
mind there so we we started to the
business grew rapidly right we went for
our i mean we've gone from
bedroom to half a billion dollar revenue
in eight years i think it was it was
like
rapid rapid growth so
during that growth period it becomes
very evident that things start breaking
if you don't have great people to manage
these things so we what we started to do
was we built essentially a chief's team
of individuals that
manage and run the different areas of
the business so chief products officer
chief brand officer you know uh people
finance all these different things and
it's just through necessity it's less of
a case of listen i think i
huge applause to a business that can see
ahead and build that team out in front
of themselves we were just at the point
of we need strength in this business
otherwise things are going to fail okay
and so when you were bringing people on
you were bringing on like c-level people
yeah for like executive roles and for
the people in hr and finance and legal
and the whole shebang and we and it was
a balance right so some people we were
bringing in with brilliant experience
and then we were also identifying great
people in the business that were hugely
devoted to the business incredibly
intelligent and competent that would
then basically be able to make that leap
up to that level as well so there's a
brilliant blend of sort of um experience
and inexperience in that team as well
okay
how did you because i guess you were the
one doing the hiring initially yes how
did you
get so and i i asked this is a problem
i'm having like
how do you hire for a role that you
don't have experience in where you're
trying to hire someone who is like good
and good at that role
if you get what i mean yeah so we i was
really lucky so i so our
our sort of current um sort of
out moving ceo steve
um he joined the business purely on good
instinct because it felt like he was the
right person to to be in the business
and conveniently he was brilliant at all
the things that i was bad at so
that one hire then allowed every other
hiring finance ops logistics all the
back end of the business then went
through him rather than the front-end
ones that went through me so it was like
one solve for
um everything beyond that which was
massive
so where you like
what were you looking for when you hired
steve
what was his role initially so i wanted
someone that would basically help we're
going to say professionalize the
business because at the time it was just
there was no hierarchy no structure a
group of people that
you know went and did a bit of brand on
the morning bit of social media event
here and there package on the evening
and your emails and go to bed it was it
was literally just carnage and chaos
as i think all businesses are the in the
early days and then he came in and he
had genuine corporate experience however
it didn't come across like corporate
experience he wasn't like you know
your typical corporate guy suited and
booted sort of thing he'd worked in in
reebok
but he also even though he didn't
understand social media particularly
well he understand the understood the
power of brand and growing a robust
business
and a great brand so
we sort of got comfortable with him and
he he ended up doing i think it was a
day a month and two days a month and
three days a month and it was a very
organic sort of shift into him joining
the business full-time oh so he started
off as like a coach consultant yeah
exactly so it wasn't like boom you're in
in the business every single day okay
and that really really helped us because
it allowed us to get comfortable with
him him to get comfortable with us and
just to get to one and know one another
oh interesting yeah because i've got a
couple of uh kind of business coaches
type people now who are mentors who've
been doing this for a few years
and i meet with them maybe once every
other week and every time i talk to them
it's like oh my mind gets blown by yeah
just all of the stuff that all of the
unknown unknowns i just didn't realize
um things like you know restructuring
your organizational chart and how when
you have the
you know there were there was a time i
think it was about two weeks ago where i
was i was chatting to this guy's name's
rohan
and i was like yeah at the moment this
is what the business looks like it looks
like this and it just felt felt a bit
like a bit of chaos
and within about half an hour he just
asked a load of questions and we kind of
on that whiteboard over there just like
drafted out to this structure
which just made so much sense and
brought so much clarity yeah i was like
i can't believe how much clarity i've
now got in my mind from just drawing
this diagram on the board it's so good
it makes such a difference
but you'll find like if when you work
with
genuinely brilliant people like that
they they revolutionize like teams
businesses brands everything like so
many people talk about all the different
nuts and bolts of businesses and brands
but ultimately it's literally just
people it comes down to people and it's
so important that you understand how to
work with people
and you know work with great people i am
similarly i was chatting to someone the
other week and i was talking about that
he was he worked with one of the most
successful business people of
sort of like my parents generation and i
just said
all right what do they do in a sentence
like
cut all the [ __ ] sort of thing one
sentence what do they do really well and
they said they attracted great people
and then left them alone and i just
thought that was so cool and i think you
know in its most simplistic form that's
what any great entrepreneur or business
person does and they do it in different
ways so some people are tracked through
insane levels of competency some people
do it through charisma some people do it
from being an incredible creative or an
incredible organizer or all these
different things but ultimately it just
does come down to that nice okay so you
were a chief marketing officer for for
how long jim trump oh god i don't know i
haven't got a clue yeah two years in the
lineup what was your role before then
uh so i did chief of brand yeah then i
came out a brand a guy called noel did
it then i sort of
i moved around and messed around with
product for a little bit and that was
that was a great period for me because
that was where i was like really in the
nuts and bolts and i didn't actually
have a job and i'll never forget this we
wanted to there was a particular product
that we wanted to make and i was
typically i'm quite impatient and it was
a case of like you can either wait for
these guys for six weeks to make it or
we can jump on a tr a plane fly over to
istanbul spend a week in istanbul sit in
the factories and make it and i'm like
too [ __ ] right i'm doing that you
know what i mean so it was like that
sort of really impulsive role product
brand moving around events
i then went from that into the chief
marketing role
marketing was great because i worked all
with social which i had done anyway i
worked with the data team and really
understood data
and then i went from there into
i did chief product officer for a little
bit a little bit of work in tech
and this is where i am today so when
you're
like
this is your company right so do you are
you applying for the position of cmo are
you just saying steve i want to see him
like what does that look like yeah so it
depends so some of them so cmo i was i
was definitely the the right person for
the role
um
i went into product out of necessity i
wasn't like i mean
in terms of immediately available
basically we found someone we did the
whole interview process we found someone
who was brilliant but they had like a
really long period of time before they
could join the business so it was it was
like it was like a 12-month period
basically where
no one does the role or i do the role so
it was more out of necessity marketing
and brand it was like it was my bag
products and then my limiting time in
tech it was more out of necessity if i'm
honest okay
and then so this transition for you now
being ceo what's what's the story there
what's that been like so far been
amazing so
um two years ago steve mentioned to me
that he thought jim shot needed a
different type of ceo to take it to that
next level
at the time i didn't think he was right
now i do
um so he's got great foresight there
so i then spent two years
working as best i could to get into a
position where i was the right ceo
because again steve steve would
basically say like you need to be he
genuinely thought i was the right person
and confident enough to do the role but
i needed to really prove it
um and the alternative was to hire
someone else now fortunately i got to
the level of being able to do the role
so two years of making sure i could
speak publicly talk to camera understand
a profit and loss properly understand
you know long-term strategic decisions
and working with teams and all that sort
of stuff which again going to the
different chiefs roles that i've done it
gave me incredible grounding across the
business which really helped and then
more recently the sort of official
transition started may 1st and it
completes august 1st and we're
we're what july now middle of july so
i'm about two or three weeks away from
like officially completing that handover
so two years worth of kind of like
training to be the ceo yes i've like
every single day
like writing a list of things i need to
do working towards them the wallpaper on
my phone would talk about the things i
need to get better at just every single
day working towards that wow and i guess
like but weirdly not having not been
able to tell anyone which is like really
weird so i'm not really wanting to tell
anyone either yeah i didn't why would
anyone tell you
because
so listen i'm more than happy to talk
about my ambitions usually but the ceo
won i didn't want people to go oh ben's
just going to get it because he wants it
so i think it was it was literally a
case of this is steve's decision it's
solely steve's decision so i didn't want
that to be you know out there as it were
i wanted to almost like work on my craft
in silence and
and then almost people then almost be
going then you should be doing that
wrong rather than me telling them okay
yeah that makes a lot of sense i guess
it
you
you must care about the brand a lot to
not put yourself in that position just
by default and knowing that you've got
all these weaknesses and weaknesses that
you want to work on yes
well clearly yeah my baby is not i love
it more than anything yeah yeah because
that was the thing that i was i was most
intrigued by when when i first started
stalking you a few years ago i was like
oh i i would have just assumed you were
the ceo um but now i think that i've got
a bit more experience in business and
like i wouldn't want to be a ceo right
now because i know that
it would just be an absolute [ __ ] show
and it's like so this is the thing i
talk about this a lot right so steve
came in and he was the best person to be
the ceo
so anyone that has an interest in
self-development would jump at this
chance because
usually there's a decision where you
focus on your strengths or you work on
your weaknesses and it's it's very
difficult to do both
in like a
in like an efficient way
because steve was so good at all my
weaknesses and running the business
i could focus on my strengths and then
have a go at my weaknesses when i want
knowing that steve would basically fix
anything that i wasn't good enough that
so i could you know steve would do a lot
of the or all of the profit and loss
sort of work but then i could just mess
around and ask questions and learn as i
go so the the best way i liken it to is
like i could focus on my strengths and
on my weaknesses i could just keep
taking the same exam again and again and
again until i got the grade that i
wanted because i could just try again
fail try fail try fail try fail yeah
because i think like right now one of
the things i'm struggling with in the
business is this thing of do we hire
people with experience because right now
our team is very young where it's like
and
i've kind of brought brought them on for
in in that apart from i think apart from
christian our editor like no one on the
team is like i think
better than me at doing
the thing because
it's like i've i was doing the thing
initially and then i delegated to them
and
that was sort of out of necessity at the
start when we didn't have much money and
didn't have much revenue coming in and
so you have to kind of get people on the
cheap as it were like at entry level
positions yeah
but now that
we're a bit more profitable it's a thing
of what my business coach says is you
really want to hire for example a
managing director or like a marketing
director or director of operations who
has 5 10 years experience because you
won't know what that is like but when
you have the right person there it will
just be like such a breath of fresh air
yeah you want you want i'm a firm
believer you want the opposite true you
want everyone in their respective area
to be better than you are and you just
amalgamate those people and you know
look at longer term strategies and
visions and you know build a cohesive
team okay but like if you're the best
editor in the business then the business
is only as scalable as you are yeah if
you're the best do i mean you need to be
able to really think about that and then
when it comes to like let's say we were
to bring someone in with experience and
they would sort of
come in at a level above other people
who've been in the business for the last
two years how how do you deal with that
like it was that like weird very
difficult yeah very difficult because
what tends to happen as well is
like
people will come in and they'll be there
from the start and that's an incredible
thing to do and some of them will be
able to grow with the business and some
of them won't and it's not a you know
it's not negative or positive on them
it's just the way it is and
like
reading between the lines it sounds like
your your business is it's elevating
itself up a level and anyone that's into
football will know that teams that get
promoted from the championship to the
premiership generally try and hold on to
the spine of the team in the core of the
team but ultimately there's a lot of
changes that have to happen for that
team to then succeed in the champ in the
premier league it's very rare a
championship team gets prepared to the
premiership and succeeds by maintaining
the same team so it sounds like you're
almost the championship team getting
promoted to the premier league and you
need to by the way it's not experience
doesn't necessarily mean competency yeah
so i wouldn't sort of i'd try and
separate those two things and sometimes
experience in certain areas can actually
be a negative because then if they've
done or if someone's done something in a
particular way for a prolonged period of
time it can be often very difficult and
time consuming to try and move them out
of their set ways so i would be cautious
about that um but ultimately you need to
understand like i don't know pick five
key facets of the business and then you
need individuals that are better than
you in every single one of those facets
and by the way it takes a long time and
it's very difficult it's heartbreaking
it's gut-wrenching it's filled with
horrible conversations you will never
want to have but if you manage to do it
you as an individual will be
incredible incredibly competent and
brilliant at so many different things
and the business and the team will be
great in the sum of its parts nice okay
yeah that's the dream um
so one thing i was going to ask you
about like you often hear for example
tennis players that when wimbledon at
the age of 23 and now they've like made
it and now there's no like they could
kind of get a bit depressed because you
know that's the pinnacle like what more
do you go for do you feel like you're in
the position of having one wimbledon at
23. i was really scared of that like
legit no no would have lie i was really
scared because
what we did is when we when we
when we did this deal and general
atlantic came in and helped tidy up the
shareholding
i did i essentially i earned you know i
own good money i and i've done okay and
i i earn really good money now and i was
scared that oh okay so
there is a
point now i'm at a point now where i'm
gonna be completely candid i i don't you
know what i mean i don't need to work i
could comfortably retire happily and i
was really scared that when that
happened that i would lose the hunger
genuinely and i was really open-minded
with myself that i would react
accordingly
to however i felt um but i am absolutely
buzzing that i'm more hungry now than
i've ever been to the point where i have
to really carefully control the amount
of work that i take on because i'm still
prone to i will just take on the work
take on the work take on the work and
like genuinely i was i was worried about
that why do you think it is that you're
more hungry than you were no idea okay i
think no so first and foremost i do
think it might not be but it could be
something to do with it being a
grandparents run their own business my
parents are so ridiculously hard working
like they will like
i speak to my grandparents about it they
work and they work in their work
um
i also think and i'm really driven by
this i'm driven by the team that i work
with and i want to do well for them and
i want them to do well and i want them
to succeed
i also think we've got a once in a
lifetime opportunity so
i don't think certainly in our
generation there's never been a brand
that has had the opportunity to go from
being you know a local brand or a
national brand to a truly global brand
um and one of the greatest brands in the
world and i think we've got that
opportunity and i feel i would kick
myself in 30 40 years 50 years time
if we didn't do everything within our
power to become one of the greatest
brands on the planet okay so it sounds
like uh it's it sounds like even from
the start like money wasn't a particular
motivator for you
no i mean listen it certainly helps and
money gives you choice
completely but the reason that the
business was started because i wanted to
be involved in fitness
the reason or one of the reasons now
it's around i think we've got the chance
to genuinely improve the world improve
people's lives and i'm fortunate right
i've traveled the world and i've met
individuals that the brand has impacted
and it has genuinely brought me to tears
at times it's incredible that feeling
and i want more of that and i want it to
impact more people and
ultimately 16 year old ben walked into
the gym and he didn't know what to do
and he was massively self-conscious and
skinny
and felt very alone
and the thought of being able to
take that away from other people and
give them a community an area to learn a
product that makes them feel like
superman i think is amazing what really
strikes me about you and on like on on
the on the interviews i've seen and on
your youtube channel and stuff is that
you seem to like genuinely breathe the
passion for the business
because
i guess if i imagine another kind of
billion dollar business like for example
for example they would have like their
vision they would have like their model
for oh we want to make the world a
better place by doing x yes and it can
always feel a bit hollow because it's
just like a corporate promise on their
website yeah but it sounds like you
genuinely like that is the thing that
trying to
genuinely love it like i said i've stood
in outside i've been to every event that
we've done like all of the large-scale
events i've traveled the world and i've
met people that have lost weight built
muscle
improved their mental health and
i mean i said at the start like the
product that we built at the start was
it was for a selfish reason it's because
i wanted that product and
i
now is it i don't know i think because
i've had that experience myself of not
knowing what to do not being in a great
place and i've felt the positive effects
mentally and physically of fitness i
would love other people to experience it
so yeah it just it really resonates with
me thick i'm excited to hear more about
your business by the way i want to see
the structure you've drawn oh yeah i'll
show you
i'm fascinated by what it would look
like yeah it's a
it's pretty simple but it's like before
it was so like
kind of all over the place and now
it feels a bit more
streamlined um because you're in many
ways your your
business model is
or it feels to me more pioneering than
what we're doing because at least we've
got we can lean back on retailers
sportswear brands tech brands all these
different things and amalgamate it into
a structure i wouldn't know where to
start with you yeah i mean the the thing
i've i'm i'm looking at
recently is uh like tv and film
production companies okay because ours
is kind of a production company right um
and like what does it look like and in
fact the new org chart like before the
way it was it was organized was
i was thinking all right well there's me
and then we've got like angus who's in
charge of like the youtube channel we've
got gareth who's in charge of like the
website yeah in charge of this uh sort
of splitting things up based on the
platform right so basically channel
split but yeah basically channel split
yeah whereas now i think what makes much
more sense is splitting it like a
production company would in terms of
pre-production production
post-production yeah so pre-production
is all of the idea generation and the
writing production is uh
me and a videographer which is currently
angus
who's also director of operations um and
then post production is our editing team
yeah and just having that structure it's
like oh okay
whether it's a youtube video we make or
a tweet thread or a blog post or even me
writing my book or an online course or
anything like that it all has that
pre-production production
post-production and therefore if we've
got angus as director of operations
managing that
then
theoretically i can give a vision
through a marketing team or directly to
our operations saying hey i want to make
a course about this thing here is my
vision for it let's make it happen yeah
and then it goes through that kind of
pipeline of pre-production production
post-production in theory and is it all
so none of it's hardware as it were it's
all software or it's content it's all
online yeah sort of tangible we have a
new like we've got our productivity
planner over there we're launching a
line of stationery go on so
you're getting a sneak peek this is like
the proof versions
the uh part-time productivity planner
what's up so why part-time productivity
what does that mean uh
part-time productivity is that so i
think one of the problems again i'm
solving yourself one thing i learned
today yeah
that's like
what have i heard that before is that
like the benjamin franklin sort of thing
oh quite yeah i think a lot of people do
this thing yeah
this is cool like what one of the issues
i have with these sort of planners is
that when they've got dates in them yeah
and if i miss a date then i just get so
demotivated and then i will never ever
use the planner again and it's going to
go in the bin yeah so this one crucially
does not have any dates on it so you can
use it some days you don't have to use
it every day yeah but every seven days
it gives you a weekly review it says all
right just reflect on your week
and that might not actually be every
seven days because you might not
actually fill it in for seven days but
yeah it's it's better than not doing any
kind of reflecting at all and you've got
my to-do list as well which are quite
nice i've never seen that before yeah i
don't like to do this because it feels
like you know i'm being a slave to my
to-do list yeah whereas i call it i
might do list because it's like oh i
could do this stuff if i wanted to and
then i feel more optimistic like yeah
why not why not
i like that that's cool yeah amazing so
we're doing like a lot of live
stationery these sort of like daily
to-do list pads if yeah instead i was
gonna ask you about this so uh these are
some of my mantras like journey before
destination
it's it's the client miley cyrus yeah um
and the theme the kind of theme of the
book that i'm writing is that
um you know it's its core message is
that productivity and getting things
done is not really about working harder
um and like the the real secret if there
is one is to learn to enjoy the journey
of what you're doing yes because when
you're having fun then productivity
takes care of itself yeah i was gonna
ask you does that resonate with you and
do you have any examples from your life
where yeah having fun has led to
productivity yes so what so for me it's
split into two distinct areas things i
love doing and i genuinely like adore
and now by the way also within gymshark
within the under the heading of gymshark
because i love gym charts so much i
would do anything within gym shop
because i just love it and i love the
fact that it speaks back to the greater
sort of mission
now within that spend a day in product
love to fly over to a factory all day go
to an event love it meet people i mean
meet athletes all that absolutely your
door every every second of it now would
i spend my sunday afternoons looking at
operational strategies profit and loss
thing do i mean accountancy finance
stuff no i probably wouldn't under the
banner of jim sharp then i again then
sort of get extra enjoyment from it the
the thing that's really helped me
massively to motivate me to do the
things in that second bucket of
things i probably wouldn't enjoy as much
is having the overarching an overarching
goal yeah so again when i had this
thing in my in my sort of site do i want
to be a ceo
okay a ceo needs to understand the
customer the product and the brand fine
got it sorted but also needs to
understand finance and logistics for
example so because i had this one it sat
under the banner of jim chart and two i
had this broader goal of i want to be a
chief exec it gave me huge motivation to
do those things and all of a sudden it
was just so easy for me to spend hours
on end learning about them because it
spoke back to a goal that i had ah okay
so i think i have to have an aim i have
to have a reason for doing things i'm
not just going to learn about something
for the sake of learning about it that i
don't enjoy okay which i would do with
other things
yeah interesting so like having that
kind of purpose that meaning behind the
thing that you're doing makes the thing
more fun yeah and then so what i did was
i said i want to be a ceo i need to do x
y and z and then i would i wouldn't i've
never been good at just like battering
something for like 12 hours straight i
would have to do it just a little thing
every single day and then having that
that goal in my head like the best
example i can give was
i want to be a ceo i'm terrible at
public speaking so i need to be i need
to get better public speaking it's like
one of my things was literally public
speaking
and then i sort of navigate through life
and as i'm an event whatever on the tube
chatting to people as you go oh what do
you do for a living spoke to someone and
they're like oh i'm a public speaking
coach and normally i'd be like
if i didn't have the goal it would be
nice have a lovely day see you soon but
because i had this goal and it was in my
list i'm like oh my god i'd love to be
great at public speaking can i take your
number can we chat some more can i learn
from you so this is why i think it's so
important to have that goal because then
i think it helps with self-development
so i think it's like if you don't aim at
something you can't i just don't think
you can get you can't just meander
through life and expect to be something
like
you can't just you know roll around and
expect to be a premier league footballer
the premier league football as a premier
league footballers because they've
worked every single day and they've
dedicated their lives to it so i think
it's the same with
any endeavor that's how i try to
dedicate my learning now have you have
you come across the the law of
attraction kind of stuff
no i've heard about it but i don't
really know yeah so it's it's the there
was this book called the secret that was
published i think a few decades ago that
like went viral back in the day and the
whole principle behind the law of
attraction is that
um it's about like manifestation that if
you if you really set a goal if you
really believe something then
the the law of attraction in the
universe will like make it happen for
you yeah then it kind of goes a bit
overboard that you know if you've got
cancer and you believe you don't have
cancer then it will get cured magically
you know the only reason you're poor is
because you just don't believe enough
that you're right
it's all yeah it's it's very very
wishy-washy um
but i think there is some truth to this
stuff in that when you
manifest when you when you have a goal
like i want to become the ceo you start
seeing the opportunities that you
wouldn't have seen otherwise you see
what you look for don't you like the
public speaking thing or you know when i
decided i wanted to buy a tesla suddenly
i started seeing tesla's everywhere
everywhere because you just have that
thing and so your brain turns on to the
the various options here so i think
that's really cool yeah honestly i'm a
massive massive advocate for that i
think just whatever it is just set a
name and and the thing is that's been
really powerful for me is i haven't gone
i want to be a ceo so i'm going to do
these massive things like set the bar so
low and it's only now looking back i've
realized everything i've ever wanted to
do i've set the bar low so
gymshark was started because i wanted to
be involved in fitness the website was
built because i wanted a website that
would transact i didn't go
i want a multi-billion dollar business
as one of the greatest brands in the
world it was just those really little
things and by setting the bar low it
then you know allows you to take those
baby steps because
nothing great is achieved in a short in
the short term it's over prolonged
periods of constant progression okay so
what's your what's your kind of low bar
now these days now that year now that
you see you honestly um consistency okay
that's my biggest thing at the moment i
just want to be consistent steve gave me
some advice coming into the chief exec
role was he said you just have to be
consistent so
i
was absolutely knackered yesterday i
went and watched the football on sunday
traffic coming out of wembley was an
absolute nightmare i had about three
hours sleep and i went in and i said if
i do one thing today
it is i'm going to be consistent through
the day and i don't want anyone that
sort of to notice that ben is really
tired today or whatever i want to be
consistent so that's my that's my low
bar thick um all right a few a few more
kind of random unconnected things that i
want to talk to you about so
you're kind of like a celebrity now
in i wouldn't say that oh well you know
what i mean you're like famous in like
what are the perks of that like do you
get cool stuff for being you like yeah
you get to meet amazing people like
really really cool people like like this
never would have happened like this is
this is like a massive pro for me
meeting i mentioned a guy called jars
earlier like i get to meet really really
cool people and like so it's you've got
the the public world so the thing i love
about youtube and podcasting writers it
gives the mass audience access to
conversations that they would never
normally have access to
and that's great but then there's a huge
group of people probably the vast
majority of very talented people that
don't really want to be on camera don't
really want to do the whole youtube
public facing thing they're just quite
happy to do their own thing
i get to speak to a lot of those people
as well that's really cool because
oftentimes that's where you like i
personally learned so much from and like
i'm trying to
i'm my sort of self-development's at a
point where it's very niche the specific
things that i'm trying to learn and so
again i'm now coming into the ceo role
i'm trying to find other people that
have done a similar scale role have had
different pro similar problems to me so
that the amount of people is is
significantly smaller so i would say
access is amazing
um and choice like you get you do get a
lot of choice within reason which is
great so access then you could just like
email like i don't know like film night
and be like bro probably not probably
not him but do i mean like within within
the uk there's so many amazing people
that i've met and it's and it's so cool
like
um
i i got to a few years ago i got to go
and spend time on downing street like i
never thought that would be possible it
was it was
life-changing for me to walk through the
gates and see that because it was just
something i never thought was possible
and those sorts of things are you know i
find them really inspiring nice that's
cool um why did you start the youtube
channel
i started the youtube channel this is
so basically i was very happy to not be
the public facing face of the brand very
happy to do that and anyone that's
followed the story will know for the
first five or six years i just wouldn't
have really posted anything online now i
took loads of content loads of pictures
loads of videos and i never posted them
then all of a sudden like the core
people started to understand and know
who i was and what i was doing at the
business and a lot of people would ask a
lot of people to ask a lot of people to
ask and i was in dublin once and a lad
came up to me and he said
i'm doing a
i'm doing a
something written a written piece on jim
sharpton i think was a degree it was
like a dissertation
and he said
can you just give me an overview a video
on how gymshark started um i said i
don't really want to do it i've been
asked before and he said come on just
one video that's it like it's what
a couple of hours of your time sort of
thing
um but i couldn't really say no and i i
hate i hate lying i don't want to ever
sort of make a promise that i can't keep
and i said you know what fine i will do
it um i recorded it two or three times
ended up deleting the footage and then
my my now fiance the time girlfriend was
a youtuber so she knew how to do it all
so she was like right sit there i'm
putting the camera on a tripod i'm going
to record you talking and then she would
basically edit edit it for me
um
so we put that live
and it just completely blew up the
reaction was amazing and it was weird
because it was like it was big on
youtube which is cool and it was big on
facebook and instagram and all the
social networks then all of a sudden
like newspapers would start writing
about it and it sort of went into that
world as well and i just kept doing it
ever since really okay because yeah like
this is an area in which i think like
there are so many like really cool
companies and really cool like founders
and ceos of those companies
but you never really hear from them
unless they're being interviewed on a
podcast yeah and so
the fact that you have got your own
youtube channel where you're showing the
behind the scenes of like just the
insane warehouse setup you guys have and
like how shopify works with you for
black friday it's all just so inspiring
and so cool to see because you never get
that behind the scenes so it's important
to me because so i mean similarly to
yourself right i love the thought of
people being better in the business that
they're working in starting new
businesses and being entrepreneurial and
creative i love that i'm really
passionate about it so i
i thought like no one else shows the in
the inside of a multi-billion dollar
brand so i thought well you know why
don't we do that why don't we show
people like
you know there are things that we will
mention and
will it give a competitor an opportunity
to do something quickly yes it probably
will but in the grand scheme of things
for me the idea of inspiring people
to build businesses start businesses and
be better in themselves is is
incredibly fulfilling nice yeah that's
really cool um
yeah every time i see that you you put
out a new video i always get excited
like yes
because i find that like
you're operating at a level of scale
that i can't even imagine and the fact
that you're making it public means that
i can now sort of imagine that level of
scale i think it was similar to
um when i first started listening to
podcasts and things like the tim ferriss
show and stuff like that see hearing
people like gary vaynerchuk where these
guys are operating at a level that most
of us just don't even know exists
and then you talk about productivity
those guys operate on a level that i
didn't even think was possible yeah
yeah it's really really cool um i'm
hoping that with this kind of podcast i
can it's a pretty good excuse to like
hang out with someone meet someone have
a long conversation um
i don't think i was going to ask about
is that i mean you know as as jim shark
has gone has gotten bigger yes
you know as like you know as a youtube
channel gets bigger you start getting
you you start to get haters you start to
get negative comments i guess
you sort of buzzfeed has had this issue
where
people working at buzzfeed or working
for buzzfeed will then make a
a thinker piece of why i left buzzfeed
that kind of thing yeah
how does that stuff make you feel like
how do you how do you deal with the
yeah so there's a point where like the
whole thing of leaving jim shark yeah
post it on youtube it would like a
massive
everyone wanted to hear about it um
listen it's gonna happen i just think
i think so the thing is
especially being in my position i guess
i'm public facing i'm not massively
public-facing there are people that are
far more so
but just growing a business
it's so incredibly tough i just feel
like i've been beaten with a stick
around the head so many times now you
just sort of get used to it um you know
i've been on the receiving end of
you know people sending me messages on
social media personally in person
difficulties in the business the growth
phase like yeah
it's
it's part and parcel of the job
um
i also by the way think that in the long
term it's a very positive thing because
i feel like i'm held to a high level of
account
um and i think that only makes me and
the business better health
because on social media anyone can call
anyone out right and if there's validity
to the claim then publicly people are
going to know about it whereas maybe in
yesteryear in my parent generation you
you would find or you'd look back and
you'd realize companies or individuals
would do bad things and sort of get away
with them and i think it's great now
that people can hold individuals and
businesses to account online
um granted sometimes it can go too far
and like cancer culture i'm massively
against i think people need to look at
things with a logical set of eyes
and like i said you know for me
sometimes it is very very tough but i
think i'm putting myself out there i'm
saying i want to be the ceo of a of a
large business and a business that's in
many ways at the center of a culture and
a community and to do that you have to
have a thick skin and you know you have
to be doing the right things and
i think i'm i think i will do those
cool um i guess finally i think i want
to ask about like what is your what's
your workflow for video production
with with like games more than me very
varies it varies a lot right so
sometimes we'll have an idea again so
the ceo video we saw obviously we saw
coming well in advance
um and we said we need to do this video
we want it to be special we actually
recorded it a few times and been the
footage because i was terrible basically
i was not very good on camera um i
didn't i just honestly it was quite an
emotional subject for me and my word
just
weren't i wasn't
even speaking in coherent sentences so
um
that one we'll all sit in a room and
work together there are certain things
which are more like paul i.e some some
people will message us and say can you
make this content sometimes i'll jump on
instagram and say what would you like to
see people will message me uh we've got
someone who's brilliant called lily and
the team who will
build out a brief so you'll start with
title and thumbnail so that's something
i was told actually a long time ago by
um a guy called john olson that we used
to work on yeah and
i said i asked him the same question and
he said i always start with title and
thumbnail nice yeah
if you don't click on the title of the
thumbnail then you can't you can make
the best video in the world but no one's
going to watch it
um so we start with the title and the
thumbnail with the the purpose of the
video what do we want to get across and
now just because of how busy the role is
i'll have a brief and i'll sort of read
through the brief okay so people want to
see this video
um i'll be sat down on a chair and we'll
we'll record basically okay
and then all of the drone footage all
the time lapses of the warehouses is
that all done right james perry who is
an absolute wizard absolute wizard
life-changing me and james been working
together for what two years now
two years and um
yeah it's been absolutely brilliant
absolutely listen i early days i edited
my own videos so robin did edit in i
then learned to edit she taught me
um it was very time consuming editing
i remember there was videos i'd spend 8
12 15 hours editing and
it just wasn't an efficient use of time
and by the way i wasn't even that good
at it then worked with other people and
and james came in and just
revolutionized the channel so what's it
like having someone film everything you
do
weird at first but then yeah
like me and james are mates anyway like
so the biggest thing when i was looking
for someone to work with it's almost
like can you you know can you edit can
you work a camera great but like it
needs to be someone that we get along
with yeah um
coverts obviously change things but we
travel the world together we've been to
the states been to hong kong we would
we'd you know be around the uk all the
time we spend a lot of time together so
we have to get on with each other and be
comfortable with each other um because
if i'm rigid on camera or
he doesn't like me then you know
yeah a problem isn't it
what about like do you do you film like
literally everything like what if you're
like having dinner with friends or like
so we wouldn't film that would we it
would be anything sort of
extracurricular would tend to get filmed
any trips will all be filmed um we'll
normally have a filming slot every week
where we'll sit down and talk to camera
we'll occasionally so james was looking
at um you're going to record for an
entire month weren't you basically
completely which is going to be really
fun for me
so we're going to do an entire month
what we'll use of that i'm not sure okay
um people love the day in the life they
love yeah so we've we've done some
really cool
high almost high budget professional
things
and then we do wander around with a
camera for a day and people just love
that so yeah
we want to bring people a little bit
more sort of in behind the scenes nice
and you just wear the microphone at all
times as well just yeah i tend to yeah
yeah
yeah
so then james ends up with like hundreds
of gigabytes of footage yeah that's the
problem that the genuine that was
another problem wasn't it during cove
video because then i would have my
camera and i would film at home and i
didn't realize just how big the footage
is nowadays when you record it in 4k
you're talking about hundreds and
hundreds of gigabytes i would have to
drive to yours with the hard drive
wouldn't i
give you the give you the hard drive
with all the footage it was just too
slow on our home internet yeah so we we
we did this whole thing where uh up so
we've got two editors in romania and
romania has ridiculously fast internet
speeds everyone's on like one like a
thousand megabytes per second like
upload download and the instant internet
speed in this place was like 20 meg
upload download it was just physically
impossible to upload files yeah so i got
like the most expensive bt infinity
option i found this guy to kind of wire
the the router from over there wire it
around the house so it feeds into this
laptop over here yeah so we use that to
upload files now so what is your
workflow so you record your videos and
then you send them out to be edited in
romania basically basically yeah and
then and then you'll comment i'd assume
because it's never going to be perfect
first time or how does that work yeah so
for the first two years i was i would
there was around a review where i would
comment on things uploaded to a website
called frame i o where you can like yeah
um affiliate link in the video
description
um
um but now like recently christian who's
my main main editor and who was employee
number one
he said that hey you know me reviewing
footage is always a bit of a bottleneck
because if i'm out then you know
whatever he was like
is there any need for you to review it i
haven't thought about it i was like oh
you're right there isn't really any need
for me to review it and so now video
videos come out twice a week and angus
is like oh yeah we've got we've got our
videos come out we're like oh yeah i
can't even remember which one that was
because we filmed it three weeks ago
yeah and we're getting into this like
production it's cool that's really
production companies
um i think one of the things that that
resonated with with what you said is
finding
finding people and building systems to
combat your own weaknesses my weakness
ironically is that i suck at motivating
myself to film videos when i'm on my own
really uh and it always felt felt like
such a such a heavy lift like oh you
know work i'd give myself i don't know
five hours to film a video and i
procrastinate four and a half and then i
film it right at the end no way um i
wouldn't expect that of you yeah mate
like
i think when i was working full-time
i had to film a video in two hours in
the evening because you so yeah
you know wake up early before going on
call that kind of thing
but when i took a break from medicine
intending to travel the world yeah which
then didn't happen because of covered
that's like i've got the whole day to
film a video yeah and then it takes the
whole day to film one video yeah
so now every thursday we have a filming
day where angus comes over it's behind
the camera and it's like all right ally
chop chop come on let's do another one
let's do another one let's do the
thumbnails and that's been really good
it's just so nice working with other
people so how does that work creatively
then like video ideas thumbnails
obviously titles how does that work yeah
so we've got a team so we have um every
every monday we have like a content
editorial meeting with me angus our
writers and
everyone rocks up to that meeting with
three ideas for videos yeah so titles
thumbnails and talking points and then i
would look through them with angus and
we would give them the green light be
like really like that one don't really
like this one hear some feedback about
that one and they would work on the
video idea the concept for the next week
and the following monday we'd have like
the full video basically ready yeah and
then i would kind of go through it to be
like okay
if i was actually filming this based on
these points you know i'd add a story
about my life over there harry potter
reference over there we'll put a story
from medicine over there
and then the video is ready to film yeah
so that when it comes to thursday we can
bang bang film four videos in a day so
when you say like bang bang bang are you
talking
would they would what would you what
would it look like to you so someone
else has come up with an idea are you
having a script are you having key
messages are you just having a title
what does that look like yeah so title
thumbnail and talking points okay so
bullet points i don't like reading from
a script it feels very inauthentic and
yeah it's
impossible um so i just like bullet
points and
the team like over time like they've
seen all my videos and so they know what
examples from my life i could use for
different things let's say we're talking
about imposter syndrome someone they
will have written oh you can talk about
when you were directing the hospital
pantomime yeah i was like that's a good
point yeah i can't talk about that and
it feels really weird and nice that
people know my life so well that they
can tell me what examples i'm gonna be
using and stuff because that's that's
the thing that always fascinates me so
like it's like scalability because
ultimately you are one person and if
you're gonna be recording then they'll
always the guys will always need you so
i'm really interested to see how that
sort of becomes scalable or do you do it
through all the different arms of the
business and the channels and you know
the products and things like that yeah
so the thing that the the the vision i
set for us i think it was this time two
years ago
i wrote it on on a page in notion of
being like basically i want us to get to
a point where the only thing i'm having
to do is talk to a camera yeah because i
think that's the only aspect of the
business in which i add unique value in
being me yeah uh to an extent in like
idea generation but like even even that
yeah cannies can be outsourced to
someone who's who's good at it
and so now we're actually pretty close
to that point where the only really the
only thing i really do for the youtube
channel is talk to a camera once a week
um what i didn't realize at the time is
that being kind of the ceo kind of role
is actually mostly about having meetings
with people and
organization clarity and setting vision
setting goals and tracking metrics and
stuff hiring hiring is a big one
looking to hire five more people and
that's been such a bottleneck for me
because we have no process for hiring
we've just been making making it up as
we went along and now i've discovered
there's all these like platforms like
workable and stuff where you can post a
job description and they will do the
applicant tracking and stuff rather than
a google google form yeah which is what
we used before and so that's kind of
where we ended up like once a week for
the youtube channel but the thing i love
about your setup and when you mentioned
you were going to bring the videographer
i was like yes because what i'm
imagining is i would love to have a
james who can like travel with me
especially as i want to travel around
the world and stuff yeah and often i
find that
in conversations with the team or in
conversations with friends asking for
advice about anything yeah i often just
come out with bangers and i'm like oh i
wish i wish i wouldn't film this yeah
that's interesting that's cool that's
really cool but yeah like i said for me
um the fact that we get on is massive
you should genuinely you should come to
jim charlotte though you should look
around our studios because
granted it's slightly different but then
we'll have the full creative sort of
sweetened team
um i think you'd love it sick we're
actually looking for a studio to film an
online course about productivity come on
have a look can we do it genuinely come
and have a look so we've got like we've
got all the ecom studios and we've got
something called studio x which is
basically an innovation studio we would
build full gym sets in there so there's
um there's campaigns we've done where
you've got like people in the gym but
they're not actually in a gym the whole
thing's just been built in that studio
nice okay that's really cool definitely
come and have a look yeah because my
personal trainer at the moment he's got
like a home gym in his garage and so
we've sort of been filming a bit of
content for the instagram there yeah
honestly
you'd love it we've done we've got all
the studios we've got the podcast studio
um it's it's absolutely brilliant
because similar to you so what you do is
like we we consider content as much of a
product as you know as desktop it's it's
exactly the same um so content's massive
for us um
yeah i think i don't i don't know any
other any other brand in your thing that
does content as well as you guys do
it's like most of them just don't do
content they do like expensive
advertising campaigns that run
a single video and that's it yes i know
and like it's i think it's just because
it's been it's been the lifeblood of the
business since day one and i think
growing up
like yeah i'd watch tv i'd watch match
of the day and stuff but beyond that
everything was on youtube and it was all
content and all of a sudden when you
realize that you can
play your part in that it just yeah you
end up building a business around and a
brand around that content and community
nice um
i think well so you who are who are the
kind of
mentors through either in real life
books podcasts who have inspired you
over the years um people should check
out
so i don't have like a defined group of
mentors and i don't have people that i
will regularly check in with as a mentor
i know some people
jim sharp will do that and it seemed to
work really well for them um steve and
paul who were the sort of original
people that helped professionalise the
business in the early days
um have been massive to me i've got a
lot of friends again i keep mentioning
jars one of the most inspiring people
i've met and like a very creative ceo
he's not a ceo as you would sort of
expect um
harley at shopify i'll sort of lean on
occasionally if i if i have a problem
that i don't know how to solve
uh online i'll watch anything can anyone
like the thing is i'm a massive believer
that
that you can learn something from every
single person that you meet and i think
i learn more from the amalgamation of
meeting a thousand people than sort of
one individual and
i'll try and chat to people that are
good at specific things there's not like
one
human who i think is the perfect human
being i'll try and pick things from so
many different people nice um and are
there any kind of
books videos podcasts that you kind of
find yourself commonly recommending to
people that they want to ask you uh you
know ben how did how did you do x or um
so again it's very similar so yeah i
read um a book ages ago which i thought
i would hate and i really liked it and i
don't actually read that much it was
called poor charlie's almanac which is
by uh charlie munger or it's it's so
it's not but it's like an amalgamation
isn't it yeah which i thought was
amazing and there was one particular
page which i can just about remember
where i think it was on why it was like
what other one or two page where he
broke down the entire success of the
coca-cola brand i remember thinking wow
this is amazing and i went into this
book thinking
he's an investor he's a financier we
have nothing in common he's an old bloke
like and i ended up thinking wow this is
amazing because he was very brand first
he's talk he talks about lots of
different sort of psychological models
and basically it's almost like imagine
you've got like a problem here and it's
about attacking this problem from a load
of different angles in a load of
different ways and it's exactly the way
that we and i try and solve problems at
gymshark and in life so i found that
book massively inspiring and then
mulling around youtube i love your
channel you introduced me to notion
notion
like genuinely life-changing and we
i mean we've run almost everything on
notion now don't we from a creative
point in the entire in the entire
business by the way not just as a meat
person i run i think you you coined it
like a life os i have my life os i have
a professional life yeah the different
gym sharks stuff everything's from a
notion so that was life changing so
thank you for that you're very welcome
um
yeah um and that's it i'll just mull
around the internet jordan peterson i
love jane peterson i'm a massive massive
fan of him i think he's brilliant um
he's really helped me as well
sick um i'd love to check out your
notions behind scenes i was gonna say
that's one of the things i thought as we
were driving down
yeah it's really cool yeah that would be
that would be pretty sick um cool and
any sort of let's say someone's watching
this and they're thinking they're they
want to get started being an
entrepreneur yeah maybe they're sort of
uh late teens early 20s haven't really
started anything yet but really inspired
by you and your journey any kind of
advice
you'd give yeah i mean it's fairly
standard right you have to do what you
love because otherwise you'll end up
you'll end up giving up um i'm a firm
believer now that there's no niche too
small especially with the internet being
so vast
i always think and it sounds stupid
saying it now if i'd have said as a kid
i want to be a professional gamer
growing up yeah my mom would have been
like you're nuts whereas now it's like a
legitimate sport career and everything
in between like even i guess with
yourself it would have been so difficult
for you to articulate what you do now as
a kid yeah i just think there's no need
too small so i think whatever it is
double down on it and just genuinely
give it a go like
gymshark was the seventh business
website product that i've made and the
other six failed miserably now
unfortunately that's not a sexy story so
no one talks about the failed apps the
failed websites they only talk about the
one that did well
and
it's a consistent theme on everyone else
that's successful that i've met they've
failed miserably so many times and
they've been endlessly optimistic about
it and they've just gone again and again
and again
yeah i think that's one of the things
that like i see this a lot with people
starting youtube channels where there's
this sense of i have to get it right
first time yeah and if you look at the
stats like the average youtube channel
takes 152 videos to get to a thousand
subscribers
and i get messages from people being
like you know like i it took my channel
52 videos in six months to hit the first
thousand subscribers and that was like a
lot faster than the average yeah and so
i get messages from people like 10
videos in being like oh this youtube
thing isn't working
keep going just try things right just
keep trying new things like i'm like
incremental improvement i think is so so
so important as well but yeah sweet well
thank you very much for taking the time
thank you for having fun been a good
chat good stuff